[Musique]
une cité balnéaire au pays des ch'tis
bienvenue à berck-sur-mer sa plage sa
rue commerçante et sa confiserie de 1922
une institution pour les habitants et
une véritable attraction pour les
touristes
lorsque jean yves matifas fabrique ses
bonbons à l'ancienne c'est toujours un
spectacle
ces sucettes sont paraît-il les
meilleurs de la région
et pourtant sa recette est d'une
simplicité enfantine l'ingrédient
essentiel de notre set c'est le sucre de
betterave
donc il faut 2 kg de sucre pouvoir faire
deux kilos de bonbons du sucre de l'eau
mais aussi un ingrédient mystérieux on
va mettre un petit peu de perlimpinpin
alors ça c'est notre secret fabrication
qu'on se transmet de génération en
génération les secrets de cette potion
magique
jean-yves en a hérité de sa mère qui en
avait elle même hérité d'une vieille
tante
voilà le sucre a atteint à bonne
température
un caramel comme autre foire sans
édulcorant ni conservateur la seule
substance ajoutée ce sont ces quelques
gouttes d'arômes naturels du parfum
désiré non classe et de l'extrait
naturel de fraises et voici le résultat
après seulement dix minutes de
préparation et on a une matière qui est
totalement transparents comme le vert
donc on va tirer le sucre pour le satiné
ici pas de paix train électrique pas de
robot mixeur tout étant le coup de
poignet donc la couleur l échange voilà
je rajoute de l'air dedans
les gestes sont les mêmes depuis près
d'un siècle pour ses clients c'est une
vraie curiosité ils viennent voir le
spectacle d'un passé révolu
les confiseurs à l'ancienne comme jean
yves matifas ne sont plus qu'une petite
dizaine en france
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'être dans
un film remonte en arrière dans les vols
à ouessant où on allait chercher son
bonbon chez le marchand de bonbons c'est
le côté naturel qui plaît je pensais
plus authentique et voilà c'est pas bon
roi du street art
mais jean yves matifas le sait bien les
rois du marché aujourd'hui ce sont les
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire ont
fait à peu près 4 tonnes 3 de sucre par
an un industriel fait pratiquement 4
tonnes par jour aujourd'hui la
fabrication des bonbons c'est ça des
robots des kilomètres de tapis roulants
des usines géantes et des millions de
sachets vendus en grande surface
cadbury kraft réglé lamy lutti soline
est et haribo ces industriels ont
récupéré 80 % du marché un marché d'un
milliard deux cents millions d'euros en
france qui est d'abord une industrie du
plaisir c'est un vrai sur un petit pc
quand on est mal ça fait du bien et
c'est aujourd'hui je pense en riant je
mange des bonbons et volage content l'an
dernier les français ont avalé deux cent
trente mille tonnes de bonbons plus de
trois kilos et demi par personne une
consommation qui donne lieu à une
incroyable bataille commerciale entre
industriels
alors comment les confiseurs méthyle
tout en oeuvre pour vendre toujours plus
de friandises et comment sont fabriqués
tous ces bonbons qui cartonne dans les
rayons
[Musique]
direction uzès une petite ville du sud
de la france à quelques kilomètres de
nîmes dans la zone industrielle
une usine qui ne paye pas de mine c'est
pourtant le site de production d'un
géant du bonbon haribo la multinationale
allemande comme l'artisan de berck
la multinationale protège ses secrets de
fabrication le site est donc strictement
fermée aux visiteurs jean philippe andré
le patron de la filiale française a peur
d'être copiés car ils fabriquent les
bonbons les plus célèbres du marché on
est jaloux de ce qu'on possède notre
plus grand bien dans l'industrie du
bonbon les ingrédients de base sont
toujours les mêmes des tonnes de sucre
liquide livrées par camion citerne
quelques additifs alimentaires et des
colorants
ce qui fait la différence avec les
concurrents ce sont les dosages et les
procédés de fabrication des recettes
connues seulement du patron jean
philippe andré et de son maître
confiseur gilbert bec
grâce à son savoir faire lusine d'uzès
produits quelques-uns des bonbons les
plus célèbres et les plus rentables de
la marque rouleaux de réglisse dragibus
mais aussi car en sac
12 45 en petit format il y a aussi les
bananes et surtout la fraise tagada
c'est l'un des fleurons de la marque
depuis 40 ans
c'est un pilier incontesté la société il
y a à peu près 60 tagada ils sont
consommés à la seconde en france
un milliard de fraises tagada consommées
chaque année en france 10 % du chiffre
d'affaires de la marque à elle toute
seule ici plus grand chose à voir avec
la fabrication artisanale du marchand de
bonbons de berck sur mer
et pourtant les deux confiserie ont été
créée la même année
[Musique]
tout commence au début des années 20 au
moment où l'attend de jean yves matifas
ouvre sa boutique de bonbons à berck à
des milliers de kilomètres à bonn en
allemagne un jeune confiseurs crée lui
aussi son atelier il s'appelle en rigole
la légende raconte qu'il a commencé dans
cette petite maison avec pour seul
capital de départ
un sac de sucre et un vieux chaudron de
cuivre
l'atelier danse rigole le voici
reconstitué dans un musée à côté de lui
jean d'uzès c'est dans cet atelier que
le jeune confiseurs allemands va avoir
une idée de génie qui va faire sa
fortune à l'époque où n'existe que des
bonbons durs lui imagine une texture
gélatineuse pour plaire aux enfants et
pour rendre sa création attrayante
il lui donne la forme d'un ourson
l'animal préféré des enfants
ne reste plus qu'à baptisé son invention
le monsieur s'appelle hans h à son nom
de famille seyrig l air y
il habite bonne bo et il cherche un nom
commercial pouvant de ces bonbons et à
l'époque on faisait pas appel à des
grands consultant des grandes recherches
marketing a ri gou et l'histoire de
haribo commençant comme ça dans cet
atelier en 1920 le succès est immédiat
en 1922 en string elle doit même
investir dans un vélo vont livrer ses
clients à travers toute la ville de bonn
90 ans plus tard le petit atelier est
devenue une multinationale
c'est désormais en jet privé que se
déplace le pdg de la marque allemande
il a 87 ans et il s'appelle hans rigole
comme papa en rigole junior a hérité du
prénom et de la petite confiserie de son
père en 1946 il l'a transformé en géant
mondial grâce un don pour le marketing
[Musique]
c'est lui qui a inventé la ritournelle
de la marque
une des premières publicités moderne
dans les années 60 elle fera le tour du
monde à la télévision et surtout hélas
exploiter à fond le filon du bonbon
gélatineux inventée par son papa
déclinée sur tous les tons et sous
toutes les formes
la marque fabrique plus de 300 sortes de
friandises aujourd'hui 6000 salariés
dans le monde
18 usines en rigole junior est
aujourd'hui l'un des hommes les plus
riches d'allemagne avec une fortune
estimée à près d'un milliard d'euros
quand il débarque en france comme
aujourd'hui à marseille le pdg allemand
est accueilli comme un chef d'état
d'ailleurs ce matin la république
française rend hommage au pape du bonbon
direction le palais du pharo où il vient
recevoir la légion d'honneur
si les décors et aujourd'hui c'est pour
les 850 emplois créés dans la région
depuis les années 70 notamment aux
usines d'uzès et marseille
voilà pourquoi docteur hans deeg
programme du président de la république
et en vertu des pouvoirs qui nous sont
conférés nous vous faisons chevalier
dans l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
on se régale junior se montre rarement
au public quand il est contraint de le
faire comme ce matin il en profite
toujours pour faire de la publicité pour
sa marque
je ne donne jamais la recette de mon
succès vous savez la recette c'est le
travail le travail et encore le travail
en dessous riggle junior cultive le goût
du secret en revanche il affiche
clairement le symbole de sa réussite sur
ses cols de chemise le petit ourson
inventée par son père
le patron allemand peut avoir le sourire
sa marque est le leader incontesté du
marché
le problème c'est que la plupart de ces
bonbons qu'on trouve dans les rayons on
finit par attiser l'appétit de nombreux
confiseurs concurrents
pour s'en convaincre il suffit de se
rendre dans n'importe quelle grande
surface le patron du magasin
daniel tignol nous présente son rayon
confiserie
en plus de ses concurrent historique
comme carambar ou michoko haribo doit
désormais affronter une multitude de
nouveaux venus leur nom vous est inconnu
et pourtant daniel tignol leur a réservé
la meilleure place sur son présentoir
normal c'est la marque de son enseigne
on appelle ça la marque distributeur
comme tous les grands distributeurs nous
avons nos propres bonbons un autre
marque un produit que l'on peut
facilement préparer la fraise la fraise
et l'audi 80 centimes l'a13 arrivons 85
centimes soit à décrocher de 20% par
rapport aux produits leaders même
l'ourson a trouvé un concurrent et là
encore c'est 20 % moins cher ça
ressemble beaucoup
bonbons haribo
en la matière ce qui plaît aux enfants
dont
beaucoup de domaines ce sont les animaux
donc ce concert que les animaux sont
beaucoup copiée mais là on ne peut pas
faire dans l'original intermarché casino
leclerc carrefour auchan
les patrons de la grande distribution
ont tous imiter l'original et le vendent
moins cher
alors comment ces distributeurs ont ils
réussi à produire un moindre prix ces
nounours et ses fraises en sucre qui
font le succès d'harry beau les
supermarchés français font fabriquer
leurs bonbons dans la même usine à
quelques kilomètres de lille
nous sommes chez lamy lutti un confiseur
de renommée mondiale
longtemps spécialisé dans le bonbon dur
le groupe a bâti sa fortune grâce à des
friandises comme celle ci baptisée
harlequins mais pour rester compétitif
l'entreprise s'est mise au joli fier
beaucoup plus rentables et fournit la
plupart des distributeurs en bonbons
premier prix et c'est frédéric
bistarelli le directeur marketing qui
nous fait la visite
là on est à peu rentrer dans le dans le
site
nous allons nous diriger vers la
confiseries gélifiées en attirant la
plupart des distributeurs dans sa
confiserie il à augmenter les quantités
produit jusqu'à 8000 tonnes par an et
diminuer ainsi les coûts de revient
le reste est une addition de petites
économies
un emballage réduit au strict nécessaire
aucune publicité et un minimum
d'innovation ici les crocodiles
ressemble terriblement à leurs
concurrents allemands
même constat pour les fraises et que
dire des oursons il semble sortie tout
droit de l'atelier danse régale ici on
imite les valeurs sûres
même si le directeur marketing s'en
défend
[Musique]
ça c'est dit
ce jeudi
blinder pris un coup franc mais
je tiens donc
wada nature ou les
[Musique]
laurence incident
maintenant son cd et livres
et bon
peut pas dire qu'ils aient démontré
qu'un
chacun sait ici
pata contrefaçon
[Musique]
y'a un boulanger est confrontée la
baguette de l'offre identifier
la baguette
non c'est pas la compétence
pour l'instant haribo n'attaque pas à
ses concurrents pour contrefaçon reste
qu'entre les différents fabricants
la bataille fait rage chaque année il se
vend plus de 20 milliards de bonbons
dans les rayons et pour conserver leurs
parts de marché les confiseurs met tout
en oeuvre pour composer des friandises
qui puisse plaire au plus grand nombre
alors comment parvient-il à fabriquer
des bonbons qui seront des best-sellers
pour le savoir
retour à l'usiné d'uzès avec le maître
confiseur darribeau pour fabriquer tous
ces bonbons des bonbons qui sont mous
canton les matches il faut un ingrédient
indispensable c'est la gélatine
elle se présente sous forme de poudre
généralement elle est d'origine animale
cela peut être du boeuf du poisson et
aussi du port comme le montrent ces
étiquettes posés sur des sacs de 20 kg
ping skin peau de porc en anglais dans
90% des cas en france
c'est cet ingrédient qui est utilisé
pour fabriquer la gélatine destiné aux
confiseurs
alors que la gingivite bien que nous
utilisons
protéines
obtenu à partir de la gélatine de porc
est obtenue en faisant bouillir la peau
des cochons récupérer dans les abattoirs
un procédé assez commun on en trouve
d'ailleurs dans beaucoup d'autres
aliments que nous consommons certains
yaourts ou margarine crème glacée ou
charcuterie mais aussi dans certains
plats allégés ou la gélatine crdp six
ans les industriels du bonbon
l'utilisent eux pour donner de
l'élasticité à leurs produits
elle a des propriétés de gélification et
les propriétés mon ressort
j'étais là
ils auront beaucoup de produits
à 5 euros le kilo c'est aussi
l'ingrédient le moins cher du marché
pour fabriquer un bonbon souple c'est
quatre fois moins chère que la gélatine
de poissons utilisés elle aussi parfois
dans les bonbons voilà pourquoi c'est
l'ingrédient préféré des confiseurs mais
au delà de l'élasticité il y à un autre
élément essentiel pour attirer le
consommateur et susciter le désir de
manger tel ou tel bonbons des fraises
bien rouge des nounours euh vert ou
orange ou des crocos jaune la couleur
voilà le deuxième secret des bonbons et
pour l'obtenir les industriels sont
obligés d'utiliser des colorants leur
nom de code commence toujours par un e
comme europ e 124e 129e 104 on les
trouve mentionné sur quasiment tous les
paquets de bonbons
et pourtant pour certains scientifiques
leur utilisation n'est pas toujours
anodine
[Musique]
dans ce laboratoire nantais spécialisé
dans les analyses alimentaires maryja y
est docteur en chimie étudie
particulièrement la présence de
colorants notamment dans les bonbons on
a le 104 qui est le jaune de quinoléine
aux couleurs chaudes le eu 124 de
couleur rouge qui est le rouge de
cochenilles et le e 129 de couleur rouge
également
donkey et le rouge allura donc sondé des
colorants synthétiser en fait de façon
industrielle dont des colorants
chimiques de synthèse des colorants
chimiques qui suscite une attention
toute particulière des autorités
publiques et de la communauté
scientifique aujourd'hui
[Musique]
donc il faut savoir qu'à compter de cet
été les produits contenant ces colorants
devront faire l'objet d'une mention
spécifique donnant en fait une
information aux consommateurs comme quoi
ils peuvent causer une hyperactivité
chez les enfants hyperactivité chez les
enfants à cause de certains colorants
qu'on trouve dans les bonbons une
information révélée il y a deux ans par
la prestigieuse revue médicale de l'inde
dans cette étude anglaise les
scientifiques disent avoir découvert que
six colorants utilisés fréquemment dans
l'alimentation pourrait provoquer chez
les enfants des troubles du comportement
une information prise au sérieux par la
communauté européenne qui a décidé
d'imposer aux fabricants une mention sur
les paquets qui contiennent ces
colorants et voici ce que dit cette
mention peut avoir des effets
indésirables sur l'activité et
l'attention chez les enfants cette étude
tombe plutôt mal pour des produits
destinés aux enfants
résultat les confiseurs ont décidé de
changer la composition de leurs produits
tous sont passés aux colorants naturels
seulement chez les fabricants comme
haribo par exemple on la met les bonbons
coûte du coup plus cher à fabriquer
c'est plus cher
et c'est sain l'augmentent ça augmente
ça augmente incontestablement le coût de
production
après vous avez deux manières d'absorber
cette augmentation de coûts de
production un par l'amélioration
constante de votre productivité votre
compétitivité notamment dans les usines
et deux de voir si vous arrivez à
répercuter sur le prix le consommateur
ce qui est comme rarement le cas
parce que si on vous remet toujours
d'une points si vous voulez rester un
produit populaire
vous ne pouvez pas répercuter tout
s'éclaire dernier ingrédient qui fait le
succès des friandises
le sucre ces mêmes l'ingrédient
principal plus de 70 % de la composition
d'un bonbon c'est ce qui donne le goût
bien sûr mais c'est devenu aujourd'hui
un sujet de préoccupation majeur pour
les autorités publiques qui tente de
sensibiliser la population face aux
problèmes d'obésité et de diabète
d'ailleurs un député en a fait son
cheval de bataille
yves bur élus du bas rhin est maire
d'une commune de 17000 habitants
lingolsheim à ce titre c'est lui qui a
la haute main sur la gestion des
cantines scolaires
alors ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette des
enfants ça le préoccupe
récemment il a même imposé un aliment
quotidien des légumes et des fruits
frais
régulièrement il fait même le tour des
établissements pour voir ce qui est
servi aux enfants
[Musique]
vous envoûter aussi de temps en temps
oui vous avez raison bonne oui elles ont
bon bah c'est pas pour moi cette
opération est importante parce que je
crois que la question de l'alimentation
de nos enfants est importante
ce que je voulais c'est leur donne la
possibilité de manger des fruits que
manger des légumes d'avoir goûté ça pour
yves bur l'éducation alimentaire des
enfants doit commencer dès le plus jeune
âge
si le député maire est aussi pointilleux
sur l'alimentation c'est que l'obésité
et le surpoids dans son département
touche de plus en plus de monde
[Musique]
c'est de la vraie phrase de france ici
en alsace 16 % d'enfants de moins de 18
ans sont en surpoids et en obésité et
donc pour prévenir ça il faut une
politique oloron long terme changer les
changer leurs habitudes éviter qu goûter
les enfants ne mangent n'importe quoi
ils burent n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai il ya six ans c'est lui qui a
fait voter à l'assemblée nationale une
loi qui interdit les distributeurs de
friandises et de sodas dans les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
et pour lui la raison est très simple il
faut bien se rendre compte que c'est la
surconsommation de ces produits qui est
aussi une un des facteurs de surpoids et
d'obésité et donc de santé pour nos
jeunes et les futurs adultes face aux
mesures prises par le législateur
certains confiseurs ont décidé de réagir
et ont développé de nouveaux produits et
des bonbons qui s'adresse non plus aux
enfants mais aux adultes
ouais là
nous sommes à reims dans une des
principales galeries commerçantes de la
ville une boutique à priori classique de
bonbons mais quand on y entre on est
plutôt surpris certes on y vend toutes
sortes de friandises traditionnel mais
c'est ce qu'il y à autour qui surprend
de la musique des écrans des publicités
pour le moins suggestive mais au goût
parfois douteux
[Musique]
bref ici on ne s'adresse pas aux enfants
le patron c'est lui laurent cordier 53
ans un spécialiste de la confiserie
il a même fondé il ya une quinzaine
d'années une chaîne de magasins de
bonbons
comptant jusqu'à 80 boutiques et l'a
revendu aujourd'hui son nouveau magasin
provocateur correspond à une stratégie
bien élaboré notre clientèle elle est
jeune elle envie de s'amuser à laisser
la vingtaine de discothèques c'est la
clientèle des cinémas une clientèle
enfantine on la laisse à la boulangerie
aux marchands de journaux ils ont acheté
le produit à la fièvre toux chez les
jeunes adultes a un avantage c'est une
clientèle qui a du pouvoir d'achat elle
n'achète pas à l'unité mais au sachet en
moyenne la dépense est de 5 euros par
personne
c'est cinq fois plus qu'un enfant dans
une boulangerie résultats laurent
cordier mise sur un chiffre d'affaires
plus qu'honorable dès la première année
donc le chiffre d'affaires ça va être
dire plus autour de 300 mille trois cent
cinquante mille euros
trois cent cinquante mille euros c'est
plus de deux fois le chiffre d'affaires
habituel d'une petite boutique de
bonbons classique si son concept marche
laurent cordier prévoit d'ouvrir 100
magasins comme celui ci d'ici trois ans
objectif prendre sa part du marché
français du bonbon à un marché de plus
d'un milliard d'euros
[Musique]